Combined with that resurgence of the national party's involvement in community politics and.
The involvement of developers in yemen. They were a couple of very controversial.
Environmental issues that were a caring mom was where the name was going to get a centralized game.
The name and village. And the other was the issue of. Waste disposal as we had a landfill. That was practically full.
I think those. Those issues especially the sewage issue really.
Polarized the village there were those people who wanted it and so it is the only solution.
And then they were the other paperless felt that we really had moved past the point of putting effluent discharge into
crakes.
Which is what was proposed for naman and that we really needed to find other molton to solutions
and that was what newman was on about. And in fact it really brought the whole sort of.
Alternative lost style debate if you lot. To hate that.
If anyway if there was going to be anywhere in australia where you would say.
Creative solutions to sewage disposal then you would expect to see it in newman. And not expect to say that.
Traditional centralised treatment works with a clue and pouring into waterwise.
The sewage issue has now being resolved in women's currently saying a centralised sewage treatment works being
installed in the pots being like throughout village. But i think the process of coming to this point.
Has been one that has been incredibly divisive. Perhaps one of the must. Controversial issues that.
The villages had to deal with for a very long time. It's incredibly. Hated to bite. It's seen.
Divisions occur in the community that. Probably never.
You know didn't exist before i believe that we got to a point where people were learning to live together.
You know quite comfortably and eight. Had respect for the other's position and points of view. But they.
The serious debate brought up a whole lot of sort of underlying prejudice.
And it was particularly strong i think because it. Focused on environmental issues and.
People who've moved to name another the last twenty years have always been very strong.
On environmental issues it's something that they felt. You know passionately about and.
While i'm not saying that the paper lived here before didn't feel the same sort of passion similar to the environment i
think that we perhaps have different solutions to the problems or perceived that there are different solutions.
And the series. The series treatment works. You know really brought that to a head.
And it's still a small drawing issue even though.
It's been resolved as far as counsel and people in the village are concerned.
And i think we'll see the effects of that at late in the nimon village for. You know quite a time to come.
I think it's been a. It's been a major disappointment for paypal who were looking for tentative solutions to naman.
I think. Niman was in a position of.
Finding it difficult to find alternative solutions however there were alternative solutions that could have been
considered. The issue there was much more that.
The state government were prepared to provide the subsidy for any scheme. That wasn't a centralised game.
In addition there were a whole lot of problems rights to around the issues that. Well if we gave everybody their own.
System in their own backyard. Who would run the system council would be paying for it. And therefore would own it.
But in. It would be on private property so there were these two issues that. Weren't resolved.
And i feel empowered that the the state government and local government. If they'd taken a more positive attitude.
To on site so his disposal and said. How can we do it rather than taking the attitude.
Well it's going to be very difficult not really possible that we would have had probably a very different outcome.
That was disappointing for late because i'd been involved in the debate for. You know two years and.
It was disappointing. For a lot of people who weren't involved in it but who just saw the outcome and.
I think it's that. There's a lesson for naman and it really. In that.
You can't afford to stand back and white took decisions.
Do you really have to be in there and be involved in the process of making decisions to have your voice heard.
I believe that if we'd had more. Import from people in the village.
And they'd been more outspoken on the issue at the time
and it was due it being debated in council with the state government.
That we would possibly have got a different outcome for the village. I would got.
Side out that i believe that that struggle in women. Will actually have impact on other small rural villages.
In that i think that we did a lot. To inform the debate on. Onslaught so is disposal and.
I don't believe that out of other villages. Looking at what i can do about. Sewerage.
Will have to go through the same things that we did and. I think that the state government.
And council will be a lot more open to onslaught effluent disposal. For other areas much more open than they were.
For name and so we've had to cater to the local government we've educated the state government. Unfortunately.
Not in time to have a different solution for women. I often hear it said.
In council by council older men and council staff. That lehman's a very divided community.
I actually don't see it as such a divided community i think it's a very diverse community it's certainly a very complex
community to have to communicate with. As an alderman to try and get a feel of what the community. Really wants.
You know what they think they really want.
It's so it's a very difficult community to try
and gauge the feelings of those paypal who aren't involved in community organizations we have quite a few.
Community organizations in newman and. The composition of those organizations. Primarily.
You know people who've lived here for a long time who've been part of this sort of traditional settlement of nimon and.
People who've moved into the area for the purpose of developing land.
So it's extremely difficult for me to find any forum whereby i can gauge the opinion of people who've settled here.
Since. Aquarius so in the last twenty years. The only way i can find out how those people feel. And.
I mean they're not united on any issue. But just to get a general feeling is to actually go out into the community.
And talk to those papers or to find people that i can be considered to be some of the k. People in the community.
Who you know i've got good networks and ask them how they think on particular issues. Unfortunately i think.
The naman and. Four people have settled here in the last. You know twenty years post aquarius. That generally.
Those people are not involved in. Muti organizations are. I think in part. They've come here thinking that.
You know they can get away from politics that they don't want to be any part of that. That.
Therefore they don't want to be part of the community. You know community groups or.
Community organization no matter in what form or shape. And i think that's. You know it's to our detriment.
In some lies because the political process has worked very much. Through. Representation to say.
Local government or state government or. You know. To whatever. Thing. And i think that.
Whilst we have people who are making representations.
To those organizations supposedly on the passage of newman and representing newman.
If the other people don't get their viewpoint. Put across. And not represented. Then i think.
You know they're generally not happy with the outcomes and don't get the benefit from that process that they could.
I'm not saying that. I think that anyone who is. You know not involved in politics is doing the wrong thing.
I recognise that sort of political involvement and. Activity. You know doesn't suit most people. But i think that.
There are other ways in which people can have their voice heard in. You know just going in.
Talking to paypal or writing letters so somehow. You know not.
Not just sort of sitting back in the hills
and letting it all happen around them all sitting at their in their house in the village but somehow getting out
and at least talking to people is that very active talking to other people about how you feel about things. Has.
You know. Impact on the outcome for the community and it might be only a tiny little thing. But you know.
Millions of grains of sand my cup of beach and. You know they all have a part to play. So i'd like to sort of.
Hope that you know i've for the next five to ten years will see.
More involvement from paypal who you know traditionally traditionally haven't been part of community politics.
Because if we've done. I think we'll say. Name and very much influence by perhaps the most. You know.
Conservative backlash and also by the interests of developers. So. I think that in the early days that was.
It was a lot easier for people to come here to just buy their pace of land in the hills just go into the hills live
into the here. Live in the hills and.
Just come into name and to do their shopping or go to list more to do their shopping.
It was much easier to live that sort of lost style.
Now i think the reality is that the hills have become you know sort of more developed this mall paypal it's much harder
to pay oscillated as it was and lars dies. And i think.
There's also the reality that that sort of lifestyle it is very difficult. It's.
We all came here with our ideals that have been sort of shaped and whittled away
and changed by the reality of living in. You know this sort of lifestyle under these types of conditions.
And it's harder now for paypal to sort of sort of sit back
and just watch what happens around them because they're going to be affected by it. That was a question yes.
I think the key thing at stake now is that newman is in the process of undergoing more change than it's undergone since.
Aquarius twenty years ago. That event had a great impact on the village and. Obviously the village to.
Change direction then. And i think now. The village is at the point of changing direction again.
And those people have moved here over the last twenty years and say in the first ten years from aquarius.
If they want to see a name
and retain the things that are important to them they're going to have to be part of that process of having a say
and of putting for putting forward. The things that they want to retain. And emphasizing.
You know the positive aspects of those sorts of things which are primarily the reasons why we've all moved to you know
the greater emphasis on self sustainability. The less consumerist lost. The not being stuck in the.
Nine to five five day a week. Work which chain doesn't mean to say that we work any less hard than anyone else.
But you know we're doing it for s l's.
If people want to retain the things that are of importance to them then they're going to have to be a part of the
process of china. In a positive way. Otherwise. I believe they're not going to be happy with the outcome.
I think things have come to a head in yemen over the past few years for several reasons primarily i believe that paper
from outside have seen the possibility of of selling them and selling them into the the broader community and.
I think you know it's. It's very real and it's definitely there. As a potential.
I think the talent niman and paper live in yemen is to try and influence that process.
And to have some say in the outcome.
For instance i believe that it's inevitable that somebody is going to stop promoting named and more strongly.
As a a tourist destination or tourist venue and. I am excited by the idea that the community itself.
Could decide what shape or form. They want that. Tourist development to take.
And i believe that if we don't do that then paper from outside will come in and do it.
Which isn't necessarily a problem. Except for i believe that they won't be promoting.
What are the things that are important to us the integrity of the name and because they don't know it.
I think the other things are that the population of women is about to grow the village.
Area has been increased dramatically. Of the last year. And we're now likely to see the population in the village.
I think the other thing that's going to have an influence on women is that the actual. Area. Of the village.
Has changed dramatically over the past year through landry's earnings.
And we're now likely to see the population of the village grow from.
Three hundred fifty to a thousand people which is going to put an incredible. Strain on the village. Resources.
But will also sort of bring a lot more people into the area.
We're also in the process of seeing the land surrounding the village.
Rezone to room residential and once again that's going to increase the population dramatically.
So there's these sort of competing interests as the population of the village.
Increasing dramatically in surrounding areas. There is increased sort of.
Tourist potential and people wanting to capitalize on that and.
There's no way that nimble in its current shape and form.
Can you know can cope with that name is going to have to change to be able to cope with it otherwise.
You know we're all kinds think and i mean that's that's not going to happen.
So i think there's a great opportunity for us to sort of say pare own future and. My word of warning would be that if.
If we done. Other people will do it for us and we won't like what we get. Niman gets a lot of publicity.
Some of it's positive. A lot of it is negative. I think. If you look at the name of nim and further afield you nuts.
Almost synonymous with the name of. You know the word drugs. I think that's.
That's very unfortunate it's a very small part of.
Nim unlock it happens to be focused on the main street which is probably why it achieves a great deal of attention.
I have seen quite a lot of. You know positive. Niman. Coverage. By the media and.
I believe that there is that really a perception. In the wider community.
You know throughout australia and across the world that newman represents a different way of living.
An alternative lifestyle. If you live. But a troy that. Challenges and confronts the dominant paradigm.
Now kind of remember. Well you know. I think that nim and certainly sick of being portrayed as.
The drug capital of this trailer. And i think it's a very unfair label. To pin on women and.
There are many of us in the community who work.
Barry had to promote the positive images of women and i mean there's a multitude of them. It's not hard to find.
You know so many sort of positive things about the name and last. I think it's been damaging to us as a community.
The way that with being portrayed in the in the media. I think it's very common for us to say. Journalists.
Come in from outside to do a story on him and when they really only get a very superficial.
Insight into the lifestyles of people here. The name and village the complexity of the issues that you know exist here.
And then go away and write a story that then. You know. On top of that gets edited.
And we get portrayed in a fairly superficial way. I've seen some very good. Mady or reports on him and i'd have to say.
And those are the sorts of things that i think we should be. You know we should be encouraging.
I think it really also is up to the community to take the initiative. To promote itself positively. Further afield.
You know throughout australia not. For the purposes of bringing tourists here.
Although it's an inevitable consequence of it. But more because i believe that women has something to offer.
To the rest of australia. You know to the rest of the world. Really. I mean we're not unique.
But you know it's just something that's happening here. And i believe that. People elsewhere would be interested in it.
And in fact i can remember there was a programme on the a.b.c. About us. Two years ago on katzman and.
The feedback from a straggler was phenomenal.
You know it was people really wanting to hear more about what we were on about the things that are important to us how
we live our lives just really sort of basic fundamental things about how do we exist and.
You know those things are exciting those are the things that i would really like. To share.
And that i'm sure other people in yemen. A quite open to sharing. You know those sorts of. Those sorts of values.
But i think we're pretty sick of being in the media spotlight when we just get portrayed in a fairly negative.
Representatives on realistic way. I think the acquiring of aquarian ideals have had to be modified substantially.
The paypal has sort of. Came here with the vision of living in the hills and of. Dropping out and.
Creating their own sort of life and values. Being self sustainable. Have had to realize that.
That's just a very difficult path.
And in fact it's not possible to cut yourself off from the rest of the rest of society
and that no matter how we lock it. You know it. It follows us everywhere. I think a lot of what.
Aquarius was the aquarius best of on its values a lot of those values are still as still relevant today that.
We've been at the forefront of a lot of change in the stroller and. Primarily you know environmental issues.
Come to mind as perhaps being.
You know some of the most important things that are less sort of consumer oriented last style.
Which was you know very much part of the equerry. Aquarius vision. Self sustainability more reliance on.
You know ourselves as individuals rather than looking at. Looking to governments.
And the powers that be to provide for and needs
and i think we have been able to sort of demonstrate that it is possible to do that around here not just around here
but in other parts of australia obviously those things are happening. I think too that.
It's given us an opportunity to enable us to provide a more sort of extended family.
To build on a greater sense of community and that's very much part of.
You know european and aboriginal law stars but it hasn't been part of. You know sort of white anglo.
Lifestyles i mean most people grow up late home and say their families that. Easter or christmas.
Whereas here i believe a lot of people. Live with that. With support from other people.
There's so much sort of stronger. Community. Emphasis in community bias and the one thing.
That is really important to me about niman is that our knowledge that.
You know if anything happens there are people here who will look after me and they are people i know.
They're my friends. And that. If anything. If my daughters walking up and down the street.
I know that there are people on the street who are going to look after her. It's that.
It's a very safe place to live and. You know it's a generally not a violent place it's a very sort of peaceful place.
I mean we might get sort of vocally. Loud with each other but there might be a lot of sort of.
You know sort of hidden violence.
Sort of domestic violence and stuff but i'm talking about generally women i particularly feel safe in newman.
It's a fairly. You know it's a safe place to be and. I think the aquarian vision was certainly to create a safe.
You know sort of happy last of the papal. It's a very sound very try. Actually and. Well take out the happy.
It is a safe place. Definitely.
I think also part of the aquarian vision was that people would be empowered to provide their own housing.
And that's been an area which i think it's been incredibly successful. There are a lot of. Own the builders.
Around here who've been able to build their houses without borrowing money.
And you know i'd like to stress that if you live on a multiple occupancy can't borrow money.
Because you don't actually own in a thing. And that's been a really powerful thing.
Because when you've got a home and you've got some security.
And i was you to move forward in life
and you're not stuck into paying off a mortgage you've got a lot more options with your life.
I think another area that's been really positive. Is the concept of shared land ownership.
There are a lot of people who would really record from that. To the idea of arming land without the paypal.
Is something that's particularly pleasant to them.
But i think in women we've demonstrated that groups of people can come together. And can on things together.
And that it can have really positive effects. Through just sharing of knowledge and skills. Through the sharing of.
Rays or says.
Through the social support network that that offers a multitude of benefits
and i'm i'm really proud to be part of a movement that's set that as an example for the rest of australia.
I guess i'd equate it with living in group housing.
In sydney where you share a house with a group of people
and i mean anyone who's lived in sydney in a group house knows that potentially that can be a very difficult situation.
And in sydney the opportunity exists where where if you're not happy in one group pass you can move into another group
house you know it keeps your rents down.
And there's more options up here it's not like that if you buy a share in a multiple occupancy it's extremely difficult
to move from one to the other.
So we're in a position of really having to work on those differences that are roz personal differences
and learning to sort of respect. Personal difference and. To respect other people's values.
And i think that's been a really valuable saying. About. You know it's sort of from the aquarius. Vision.
And i think we've learnt a lot about communication. We've learnt a lot about. Conflict resolution.
We've learnt a lot about. Just developing our own personal skills and. Those the sort of benefits.
That you know the rest of the rest of the community benefits from when we then take those into a community
or a narrow and i mean community in the broader sense not a multiple occupancy community.
I think the benefits for for children of this sort of lifestyle.
Tremendous i mean firstly they get to live in a rural area. And i think that has a lot of.
A lot of benefits for children. They've got spice that quite a beautiful environment.
I think also the fact that they do.
They are part of an extended family and extended social network is also of incredible importance and.
I'd have to say on a personal level as a single parent. It's been invaluable to me. The support that are being given.
Not only by my community in the paper that. I live with. But also by people within the newman area.
Generally i think also there are lots of things being offered here. To children.
That perhaps don't exist in say you know. In city areas.
So they're learning some really valuable skills
and i my own daughter already helps me with building you know she'll pick up a hammer and have to pick up a hammer
and to line lutie at the age of thirty or whatever it was
and dad just having a very a very physical life which most children who live in rural areas head butting you know
tional together with stuff. I think another benefit for children is just the range of. Schooling.
And educational options that are available to them here. I think.
In the name an area we have six or seven different schools. With different educational. Philosophies and.
Parents are able to choose to a degree you know which school they send their children to that will most suit the needs
of their children. I can't think of.
You know many other places where that sort of range of options would exist in a rural area.
I think i'd have to say that my concern. In relation to young people living in this type of environment.
Is when they reach teenage years. It's very often that those. At those. It's very often that. At that age in your life.
The most important thing for you is to be with your peers and i can remember that myself.
And although i lived in a in a rural area it was only two miles for me to get into town and i could walk it.
Whereas for many people around him and i live a lot further at.
Town than that and it's much harder for teenagers to be able to get into town to spend the night in town.
Leaving in town and then to be able to get safely home. I think that. Communities really.
Still need to do a lot of work on what they offer their teenage youth.
And it excites me to see a community like town to befalls community.
You know one of our most established community actually putting a great deal of time and effort
and resources into looking after their teenagers and trying to give.
Tane i just options within their own community that mean that they can stay there for a community like. My own.
Where we have a much smaller population. There's a lot more pressure on us to get out children into town.
To sort of be part of what's happening there. And then to be able to get them out again.
So it is a challenge for us and it's one that i don't feel that we have. We have adequately. Addressed.
I think the other problem for us is the fact that we do have a drug scene that so concentrated on the mind straight
and it is a sane that's very attractive to. You know teenage. Youth when they're going through that sort of.
Rebelling against everything. Cutting ties with the family and stuff.
And that's a concern to me i think it's really important that we offer our children a safe straight.
And i believe that whilst in lots of ways it is a very safe place to bait the drug scene is something that we haven't
really come to terms with and that it does have this sort of almost fatal attraction to taina edges.
And some of them will get sucked in and. You know most of them don't. But some of them will. And.
Somehow we have to look at that as a community
and i think it's probably one of the most difficult problems that we face.
And yet one of the most important because it's the thing that most directly affects our own children.
It really concerns made that. A lot of that teenage youth that really end up leaving them then.
And i'd like to think that we had more to offer in terms of job opportunities.
People creating their own employment i believe that you know i mean teenagers generally lay them want to go somewhere
else. And it's happening from a to say. You know some of those teenagers that surely.
Return to newman after they've been away for a while and.